[Music]
disney and pixar seoul streaming on
disney plus december 25th
music is all i think about
from the moment i wake up in the morning
to the moment i fall asleep at night
i was born to play
it's my reason for living
[Music]
oh
hmm this weed the council
there's a soul missing
this is heaven no is it h e
double hockey sticks hell
[Music]
no it's the great before this is where
new souls get their personalities
quirks and interest before they go to
earth here we are
don't worry you can't crush a soul here
that's what life on earth is for
oh it's my life
can you help me get back come on
this won't be a disaster that's for sure
you're out there somewhere little song
and i'm gonna find him
life is full of possibilities
[Music]
you just need to know where to look
[Music]
don't miss out on the joys of life
like uh pizza i can't smell
we can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch see
okay i get it disney and pixar's soul
get ready your life is about to start
start streaming december 25th
[Music]